Hallo ihr Lieben! Heute gibt's mal wieder ein leckeres Apfelrezept von mir.
Wer mich schon länger kennt, weiß: Ich liebe Apfelrezepte!
Und ich werde euch auch am Ende des Videos meine Apfel-Playlist verlinken.
Heute gibt's einen hübschen und sehr, sehr leckeren Steppdeckenkuchen.
Wir machen dafür zuallererst den saftigen Rührteig.
Ich nehme natürlich heute meine Küchenmaschine weil wir den Teig später 5-6min lang schlagen werden.
Ihr könntet alternativ aber auch euer Handrührgerät verwenden.
So, die ganz genauen Mengenangaben schreibe ich euch natürlich wie immer unten in die Videobeschreibung.
Und ich gebe jetzt zuallererst Eier, Zucker und eine Prise Salz in die Maschine
und schlage sie dann wirklich 5-6min auf maximaler Geschwindigkeit richtig schön hell-cremig.
Nach der Rührzeit fügen wir dann noch Sonnenblumenöl und Milch mit in den Teig
und rühren das wirklich nur für ein paar Sekunden unter.
Als nächstes kommen Äpfel mit ins Spiel
Und bei den Äpfeln könnt ihr jetzt bei diesem Rezept darauf achten, dass ihr säuerliche Äpfel verwendet.
Die schmecken dann später einfach viel besser und harmonieren auch mit dem Zucker.
Dieses Video heute entsteht in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Qualitätssiegel Südtiroler Apfel g.g.A.
Wer mir vielleicht auf Instagram folgt, hat dort schon das eine oder andere Rezept mit diesen besonderen Äpfeln gesehen.
Ich wollte euch aber heute auch nochmal näher bringen, was das Besondere an diesem Qualitätssiegel ist
und woher die Äpfel genau kommen.
Ihr könnt euch das jetzt einfach so vorstellen, dass Südtirol das perfekte Klima bietet für vollaromatische Äpfel.
Ganz einfach weil es in Südtirol im Schnitt 300 Sonnentage im Jahr gibt
und das Klima aber recht mild ist.
Vielleicht kennt ihr auch diesen Aufkleber, den habt ihr mit Sicherheit im Supermarkt schon mal gesehen.
Da steht Südtiroler Apfel g.g.A. und g.g.A. bedeutet ganz einfach "geografisch geschützte Angabe".
Und das sind wirklich Qualitätsmerkmale, die geprüft werden
und daher bekommt auch nicht jeder Apfel dieses Qualitätssiegel.
So, und jetzt machen wir folgendes: Wir schälen die Äpfel und reiben sie ganz fein.
Ich persönlich finde: Je feiner, desto besser!
Wenn ihr grobe Stücke habt, dann macht das nicht ganz so ein schönes Mundgefühl.
Und wenn ihr sie eben fein reibt,
dann kann es richtig schön in dem Rührteig verschmelzen.
Und die Sorte heißt übrigens Granny Smith.
Und ich mache es jetzt so, dass ich meinen Apfel direkt in den Teig reibe
und dann wirklich nur ganz kurz unterrühre.
[Hamza] Granny Smith oder Granny Thmith?
[Kiki] Granny Smith!
[Hamza] *lacht* Du kannst das nicht aussprechen!
So, ihr Lieben! Der Teig ist fertig, der wird auch sofort weiterverarbeitet
aber ich zeige euch noch einen zweiten Teig, den wir dann für die obere Schicht verwenden.
Und der ist innerhalb von 2min zusammengerührt.
Ihr braucht dafür Doppelrahmfrischkäse, ein bisschen Quark,
da könnt ihr gern Magerstufe nehmen oder den 20-%igen, den habe ich heute genommen.
Und dazu gebe ich ein Ei, Zucker, Vanilleextrakt
und ein bisschen Speisestärke für die Bindung.
Ihr dürft die Quark-Frischkäsemasse nicht zu lange rühren.
Das ist super, super wichtig weil sonst wird die Masse total flüssig.
Also nur ein paar Sekunden, das reicht vollkommen.
Ich hab mir das jetzt auch schon umgefüllt in meinen Spritzbeutel mit einer kleinen Sterntülle vorne dran.
Das brauchen wir gleich und das ist so ein Part, der einfach richtig Spaß macht!
Aber zuallererst füllen wir jetzt unseren Teig in einen Backrahmen.
Den habe ich eingestellt auf 26x36cm.
Und da dann einfach den Teig reinfüllen und alles schön glattstreichen.
Jetzt gebt ihr die Quarkcreme als Gittermuster auf den Rührteig
und die Creme reicht wirklich perfekt aus.
Und das Schöne an dem Kuchen ist: Ihr habt halt nicht nur diesen saftigen Rührteig,
sondern auch gleich noch sowas - so 'ne Quarkmasse mit drin!
Weil ich persönlich bin so ein Mensch: Ich brauch dann immer noch 'nen Klecks Sahne oder so obendrauf.
Und das entfällt hier komplett weil das einfach schon perfekt ist!
Ich backe den Kuchen jetzt im vorgeheizten Backofen bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze
für ungefähr 25-27min.
Achtet darauf, dass es schön goldbraun ist, macht gern die Stäbchenprobe.
Und zum Schluss gebe ich dann noch so ein bisschen Puderzucker obendrauf.
Und spätestens jetzt wird auch klar, warum sich dieser Kuchen Steppdeckenkuchen nennt!
Weil der sieht 1:1 aus wie eine Steppdecke!
Also so richtige Verb- so richtige Verwechslungsgefahr!
Macht ihn unbedingt nach!
Ich habe den jetzt schon ein paar Mal gemacht und finde ihn unfassbar lecker.
Und wenn ihr den Taste Test vom lieben Hamza sehen möchtet,
dann bleibt auf jeden Fall bis ganz zum Schluss dran.
Ich wünsche euch an der Stelle noch einen wunderschönen Tag und bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
[Hamza] So, Leute!
[Hamza] War cool, ne? War cool!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Probieren wir mal den Kuchen jetzt. Du hast den ja so hochgejubelt! Ähm...
[Hamza] Sieht auf jeden Fall lecker aus. Bin mal gespannt!
[Hamza] M-hm, m-hm, m-hm!
[Hamza] Warte mal. Ich muss noch ein kleines Stück probieren, damit ich das wirklich ganz sicher beurteilen kann.
[Kiki]  Okay.
[Hamza] M-hm, m-hm, m-hm!
[Hamza] Soll ich dir mal kurz und knapp sagen?
[Kiki] Ja?
[Hamza] Das ist ein Kuchen, der geht immer!
[Hamza] Wenn du Besuch hast und den dann servierst, sagt er: "Ey, ich bin eigentlich voll aber komm, den ess ich noch!"
[Hamza] Und das geht dann halt!
[Hamza] Und ich finde vor allem das ist so ein Kuchen, das würde auch die ältere Generation sehr, sehr lecker finden.
[Kiki] Oh ja!
[Hamza] Weil er nicht süß ist.
[Hamza] Und weil's halt so ein typischer Apfelkuchen ist! Weißt du, was ich meine?
[Kiki] Ja, der ist nicht zu süß aber -
[Hamza] Der ist nicht süß und der ist auch saftig.
[Hamza] Man sieht die Vanillepünktchen Kiki, das ist ganz wichtig!
[Hamza] Aber das harmoniert sehr gut. Gerade mit den Äpfeln auch zusammen - mega!
[Hamza] Also der Kuchen geht immer. Ganz kurz und knapp: Der geht immer, Leute. Wirklich!
[Hamza] Das ist mein Fazit.
[Kiki] Ja, Dankeschön. Danke für dein Fazit!
[Hamza] Gerne doch!
[Kiki] Bis zum nächsten Mal.
[Hamza] Nein! Du kannst den Abschluss nicht machen, den muss ich machen Kiki!
[Kiki] Achso tschuldigung!
[Hamza] So Leute, ich wünsch euch noch einen guten Appetit falls ihr den Kuchen macht.
[Hamza] Genau. Liked, abonniert schön den Kanal weiter.. peace and out!